[Musica]
e tutti ricorderemo
per sempre sarà scritta nella nostra
storia dell'italia accendiamo il
televisore e vediamo
il decreto che sancisce la chiusura dei
confini del nostro paese
delle nostre regioni per le nostre città
e per la prima volta ci chiude in tanti
in pochi metri ma vi rendete conto
nessuno lo avrebbe mai pensato
si dice che il battito d'ali di una
farfalla
dall'altra parte del mondo abbia
veramente un grandissimo impatto dove
siamo noi
e così è accaduto dalla cina che
sembrava così lontana un paese così
distante
eppure da lì è arrivata in europa è
ancora nelle americhe non ha risparmiato
proprio nessuno
questo virus invisibile
guardate
lo avreste mai detto che avremmo visto
una città tanto deserta che saremo stati
chiusi mesi e mesi nelle nostre case
incredibile se dovessimo guardare
attraverso questo scorcio che vedete
osservassimo
queste città
guardassimo nel passato se vedessimo la
nostra storia non solo la nostra storia
italiana ma anche la storia degli altri
paesi
vedete è vero abbiamo vissuto delle
crisi devastanti prendiamone ad esempio
l'attacco alle torri gemelle 11
settembre 2001 siamo usciti da quella da
quell evento con una paura terrore le
nostre relazioni
sicuramente si sono modificate ma mai
come adesso
perché vedete in quell'occasione
nonostante la paura del terrorismo
nonostante davvero il il terrore per gli
attentati e ancora vediamo un altro
esempio il nel 2008 lehman brothers il
fallimento di una delle più grandi
banche d'investimento del mondo
sembravano assolute certezze eppure a
oggi se facciamo un paragone con quei
quelle crisi se i nostri figli
leggessero un domani delle crisi che
abbiamo vissuto che vi menzionavo e
guardarli ma quello che è successo oggi
sarebbe riduttivo fare un termine di
paragone
perché prima seppur con dolore seppur
con paura ritornavamo alle nostre vite
ritornavamo la nostra socialità
ritornavamo a vedere gli altri ad oggi
è molto diverso niente avuto più impatto
sulle nostre relazioni di ciò che
abbiamo vissuto in questo momento ed
emerso l'emozione il fattore più
invalidante dell'essere umano
la paura ma vedete come ogni onda come
ogni grande rivoluzione abbiamo due
opzioni cavalcarla e quindi controllare
questa rivoluzione questo cambiamento
questa crisi consapevolmente seguirla
oppure lasciarci trascinare e vederla
come una grande minaccia invece che come
un'opportunità e così forse sarà per
molti di noi ma spero davvero che
riusciremo seppure con dolore cogliere
questa opportunità ea trarne qualcosa
vedete prendiamo un esempio lo smart
working il tanto discusso smart working
ad oggi non è più un'utopia è una realtà
lo vediamo in tutte le aziende ad esso
ormai ormai è obbligo quasi e vedete se
guardiamo al passato tante
multinazionali negli ultimi anni hanno
provato a implementarlo come metodo di
lavoro ma non ci sono riusciti perché
mancava la fiducia non ci si fidava e
quindi non lo si utilizzava e adesso ci
troviamo in un momento in cui per forza
dobbiamo fidarci
non possiamo permetterci più di non
fidarci deve nascere un altro spirito di
collaborazione fra le persone era già
necessario prima ora
vi lascio lo lascio a voi e quindi ad
oggi è diventato davvero fondamentale
avere una cosa per fare business
vi rendete conto oggi possiamo fare
business anche da casa e serve una sola
cosa la credibilità senza quella signori
non potremo muoverci
abbiamo una grande un grande strumento
che la tecnologia
vi rendete conto negli ultimi decenni
tutto sommato possiamo davvero
organizzare il nostro tempo utilizzare
questa questo strumento per tenere delle
relazioni con le persone averle anche in
un modo nuovo in un modo diverso
vedete abbiamo una libertà diversa se
vogliamo vedere questa onda questa crisi
anche come un'opportunità ad oggi
attraverso uno schermo possiamo
interagire con infiniti contatti
invisibili ma potenziali per noi e
quindi quando andiamo attraverso i
nostri social attraverso i nostri
strumenti oltre alla credibilità e la
fiducia
cerchiamo di capire chi influenza che
cosa perché ognuno di noi influenza
qualcosa o qualcuno
chi decine di centinaia di migliaia di
persone circondiamo c di queste persone
per espandere le nostre relazioni e
creare delle sinergie
oggi se lo vogliamo
il mondo è nelle nostre mani grazie
[Applauso]
[Musica]